crime rates are rising in many cities
all around the country and law and order
has become a top concern for voters and
today's maryland primary democrats are
now testing each other on their
crime-fighting credentials less than two
years after the era of defund the police
kaitlin huey burns looks now at this new
political reality in maryland
crime is definitely a concern for
baltimore teacher angela chambers crime
in her city is more than just a headline
we as a community
and i mean people i mean politicians
from the base
all the way up have to unite together to
decide what are we going to do it's an
issue front and center of the democratic
primary for governor in maryland i'm
doug gansler running for governor as
former attorney general i have the
experience and plan to tackle crime now
wes has a plan he'll help get guns off
our streets the crime issues that we're
confronting here are not unique to
maryland tom perez running for governor
tom perez chaired the democratic
national committee in 2020 when some
activists pushed for scaling back police
budgets and prosecutions in the wake of
george floyd's murder what i have said
is we need to work together and invest
in making sure police departments are
effective
and are respecting the constitution
gansler advocates for adding a thousand
police officers statewide on tuesday we
are going to stand up and make our
voices heard while wes moore a former
non-profit executive endorsed by oprah
says root causes must also be considered
this is a major issue for people people
want to feel safe the candidates are
going to be rewarded are the candidates
who are really thinking holistically the
executive director for progressive
maryland says it will all come down to
which candidate can convince the party's
base democrats have had like a
tough challenge making sure that
populations that are concerned about
safety
also feel like they're being serious
about addressing violence in their
communities
now republican primary voters will have
to decide if they want a candidate
backed by the popular outgoing governor
larry hogan or a candidate backed by
former president donald trump and that's
a very tight race between hogan backed
kelly schultz who's the former state
commerce secretary and trump endorsed
candidate dan cox now the results here
in maryland will not be determined for a
while because mail-in ballots can't be
processed until thursday tony
don't want to count them quick you want
to count them correctly caitlyn huey
burns for us caitlin thank you very much